you need three books to play D and D you
need the player's handbook you need the
dungeon Masters Guide and you need a
monster manual from there it's pretty
self-explanatory make a character you're
going to get between 50 and 70 percent
of how to play D and D or at least all
the necessary questions you're going to
want to ask from creating a character so
crack a player's handbook pick a race
Pick a Class pick your background get
your equipment set your character up
then from there somebody's going to need
to run the game so if you're ambitious
you love storytelling the way that I do
you're going to lean into becoming the
dungeon master rather than a player now
dungeon Masters you're going to want to
read the dungeon Masters Guide get
acquainted with the monster man you'll
see what monsters in there you like you
don't you want to throw at your
characters blah blah blah then you're
going to want to either home brew an
adventure which means you write your own
or the other option I would say that
just simplifies things is to get the
starter kit which is a boxed set